こんにちは
化粧水をつけていない男様をつけないと
年をとると肌が
方がさせるぞ
肇社長ですまっつーわけで男で何か化粧水とが使ってないといったらもう使った方が
いいですよ僕使い弾みたのがだいたい21歳頃なんですけどもあのお肌のケアが大事
ですよ
多分てる私ですねお肌なんか技巧派が弱くて荒れやすいんでなんかこう肌はきれいに
保つためにないすればいいかなと思ったんですけどまぁ決勝生動物等なんですけども
最近だとお薬を飲んでおりますでどんなお薬を飲んでいるかというとこれもあの病院で
もらったんですけどこれとこれとこれとこれですね
多いのが多いんですけどなんか全然これそんな強くないらしくてなんか長い期間ずっと
持ってったらよくなってくるみたいなやつなんですけども
お薬たくさんあると思いますでいろんな形の薬があるんですよコレだか丸いタイプも
あれば中
丸いタイプもあれば
基本ある伊那北これを見せたいんですけどもこちらこういうカプセルタイプのお薬って
あると思いますでこのアフせるタイプのオークスにノースゲームを見つけましたこちら
一応炎に聞いてるんですけどいきますよあの
生きていますこんな感じますあげますよ
ぶーぶーっ
ねーっまぁねぇ吠えません
墨彩画と低価格で動くぞおえええ
ううううういっ
[音楽]
どうすかこれ動画ただの薬がですねこうやって動かすと勝手に動くんでてほらも生き
てるみたいにパッと日どう見てもくせいですよね
で普通の曲でおいてももちろんあの辺で動きなんてしないで普通に転がるんですけども
えぇっバッハ
me
うーん同大凄くないですかこれ知ってる人いるか分からないんですけども生きている
カプセルっていうのが売っておりました僕今日これを知ってめっちゃ衝撃を受けたん
ですけどすごくないからもちろん普通の活性度ほぼ大きくは変わらないんですけども
本当に動きだけがすごいんですよところですね動かすとなるで生きてるか前に動くよう
な不思議なカプセルでございますだってこれ
あれじゃあもうすごくと別にてるんですよもうしてました
芋虫はなんかこうやってご関係ですかめっちゃその動きに入ってるんで
初見でよ初見でもしこんな3位も白さ
今もして直径ネタもした此方を食べようとしてたおっ薬ですねこれ
ウィードを知った毛布白6系ってめちゃくちゃこっこれ
という分けて今後はこのまでで言ってるようなお薬のカプセルを使って能郷としていた
薬が凸で動き出すドッキリを仕掛けたいと思いますもういたって簡単でしょ
ターゲットを読んでこれを肌に効くを曲でめっちゃ悪い人みたいですねターゲットを
読んで何かお肌にいい曲だから飲んでみナッツってやって b 感じにこの生きた
カフェ論は
だしてう2-6ずどれっ子でとってへ手渡すときにどうやって渡そうかな
ターゲットが入ったよこれめっちゃかないっていうかいいをのムってとってあげて
あってドサクサに紛れてタオルに傾斜をつけていきますってこのまま
こうすれば見ること間違いなし
俺の存在知ってるとマジで意味のないことになっちょ
トプ画なんですけども竹とこの生きたカプセルの存在知らないことを辞退しております
で like を考慮
さあプレイしますではなくその体質所なんだけどインタビュー的なんだねれてないん
ですよねーでないと方が荒れてきてで応援フェアどうせ顔肌と示してますよ
のものもやっぱ結構不規則じゃないオーグやってロスちょっとねちょっと狙いあると
そこでご覧ください
ブーバーてないんからキャロさあ
何もになりますどれがどの高架化ってわかります
あーで21条いけないけどてもいいですかそんな普通に一般に普通に買えたから
たドアのお医者さんに許可もらってるてでもう一個いいのがあって
うーん
絶対ながらいいん
これもめっちゃいいんだねこれウンスクん
これも普通に置くするん
それっ
ブーブー do
me
ええええええ
うううう
dare
me
あっはぁ
何無償思ってるよ中にね
一周駅伝だよ行きたかってるよ
[音楽]
日
絶対 b なるようなんならないバッ
pa
えええっちょっ